take the faces voices and over-the-top
theatrics that have made the Yakuza
franchise renowned and transport that
all back to the 19th century Japan the
result is like a dragon ishin an
enticing period piece that also includes
the series action baller gameplay and
ridiculous hijinks even though the
context has changed swapping The Gangs
of the modern criminal Underworld for
political factions in a tumultuous time
in history ishin is yet another example
of what developer rgg Studio does best
melodramatic storytelling it's been a
long time coming as Yakuza ishin
originally a PS3 PS4 game from 2014 was
not previously localized and brought to
the West like other entries in the
franchise this new version lands
somewhere between a remaster and remake
but it is based off of older iterations
of Yakuza games which makes like a
dragon ishin feel dated in several
respects particularly in
moment-to-moment gameplay still its
fundamentals are solid and the main
draws of the franchise remain intact
hooking me with its characters and
twists that had me eager to see its
historical fiction unfold from chapter
to chapter
[Music]
instead of the glitz and Glam of
camarocho ishin takes us to late Edo
period Japan around the time of the end
of the Samurai class and just before the
country's modernization in the same way
previous Yakuza games offer a sort of
visual tourism ishin's Vivid
reconstruction of Japan's past albeit
with more creative Liberties delivers
the same Thrills the streets are filled
with menacing men wanting to cut you
down as you mind your business strolling
through the markets restaurants and bars
represent the era's cuisine and tons of
side content reflect the culture and
traditions of the time while it may not
be as dazzling as the neon lit streets
of the modern day the more low-key
setting of Kyo which is now modern day
Kyoto is refreshing and a welcome change
of pace that lets the Yakuza formula
Thrive once again within a framework it
is comfortable with
foreign
of the Edo era is fertile ground for
ishin's historical fiction it's a time
in Japanese history where internal
conflict and political Strife came to a
head with various factions vying for
power leading to a transitional phase
for the country ishin uses this as a
stage to tell another story of betrayal
conflicting ideals and seeking personal
truths but fits it into a pivotal time
of widespread violence and societal
turbulence ishin melts these parallel
themes gracefully using strong
characters as the focal point for both
the gripping personal drama and the
escalating struggle for power to steer
Japan's future by using the same
character models and voice actors from
the Yakuza Pantheon ishin creates an
immediate familiarity that made me feel
right at home but ever curious about the
direction of its story series Legend
Kazuma Kiryu takes on the role of
ishin's protagonist Ryoma Sakamoto or
hajima Saito as an alias Loosely based
on the revered real world figures of the
same names other favorites like majima
saijama and akiyama fill in the roles of
soji okta shinpachi nagakura and katsura
kagoro just to name a few it's wild to
see such an All-Star cast Don the names
and roles of historical figures but
what's more striking is that each
character remains true to their ethos
and personality from the mainline games
however ishin does take its time to get
the ball rolling it wasn't until roughly
eight hours in around the halfway point
that I started to see the various pieces
fall into place and the story come into
clearer focus it drops a lot on you
front loading the story by establishing
factions political terminology and the
Deep cast in a way that can be tough to
follow if you're not already familiar
with Edo period history ishin is
ambitious in that way trusting that you
can keep up and track the things it
throws at you but at the same time the
first half sort of spins its Wheels
before having real consequences and
character motivations take Center Stage
once the tangled web of alliances
started to carry more narrative weight
however it was hard to put down as the
momentum of the drama propelled me to
the end leaving me eager to find out
what happens in each subsequent chapter
I've played too many of these games to
be completely surprised by its plot
twists at this point but Time After Time
Yakuza games still activate those good
brain chemicals with its cinematic
storytelling Panache and ishin is no
exception
's tried and true action baller combat
serves as a sufficient vehicle for all
the gripping drama and Larger than Life
characters it's similar to the Yakuza
games of old but with a focus on
swordsmanship and Firearms the four
fighting styles feel more distinct than
the various stances from previous Yakuza
Brawlers and have their own advantages
in certain combat situations
[Music]
I can elegantly slice through a crowd of
enemies with the Nimble wild dancer that
combines sword and handgun then switch
to The deft-handed Swordsman stance to
lay on heavy damage in one-on-one
battles the grappling-based brawler
meanwhile can be used for brute force
and the gunman can chip away at enemies
from a distance which helps mix things
up
can be as technical as you want it to be
even though basic hacking and slashing
can get you through most of the story's
battles well enough like other entries
you'll fight through hordes of enemies
in story driven scenarios and they tend
to have a bag of cheap tricks in their
back pockets that are inoffensive at
best and annoying at worst on the other
hand ishin's boss fights are a highlight
which feel less like a war of attrition
and more of a duel between skilled
Swordsmen and these battles are topped
off with over-the-top theatrics in true
series fashion I can stab a dude in the
gut five times and fire 10 shots Point
Blank but when the dust settles those
gruesome heat actions were just a
bloodless way to settle the score
this new version of ishin is faithful to
what the original was when it came out
in 2014 and uses an identical gameplay
Foundation from the older series entries
so while it's rebuilt on Unreal Engine 4
it plays much like Yakuza 0 and Yakuza
kiwami however that's a notice
accessible step back after five other
entries in the modernized dragon engine
especially coming off the latest in Lost
judgment which featured the best brawler
combat system rgg has made thus far
playing through ishin it's clear how
much the series has evolved with better
fluidity of movement and how that
manifests in a more robust combat
experience even though I can enjoy it
for what it is I had to place the game
in context and keep my expectations in
check the older Tech shows its age in
other aspects quality of life features
seen in later entries just aren't
present here with the dragon engine
having flexed the seamlessness of
walking into the various shops and
establishments the segmented design of
the open world reminds you that this is
a game of generations past the actual
content of the various activities that
fill the streets of Keo however are as
good as they've always been signatures
like rhythm-based karaoke feature a
playlist of bangers that has Ryoma on
stage singing his heart out to a crowd
of bar patrons go good old Baka mitai
gets another goofy rendition here and
finally I get to play through the
original Foxy version of ichi Sakura
which grabs you with a catchy somber
Melody and voice actor Takaya coroda's
deep tones
[Applause]
[Music]
and as someone who loves Rhythm games
the fan dancing minigame and substory
had me sinking even more time in
chaining combos to some catchy Japanese
folk tunes as Ryoma showcases his
elegant traditional moves
[Applause]
I sunk the most time into farming
fishing and cooking which all feed into
the side content dubbed another life
here Ryoma lives off the land as you
manage crops to grow in the backyard of
his own home as you harvest fruits and
veggies and reel in more fish from the
rivers and Open Seas you can cook more
more dishes cooking is done through cute
little mini games that reward you with
food as powerful healing items and extra
money if you want to fulfill food
delivery requests
it's also how you connect with ryoma's
adoptive daughter harika who is
essentially the same character as in the
mainline games as with any yuck as a
game sub stories litter the streets as
either short diversions for silly side
stories with absurd or heartwarming
moments you'll be doing a logic exercise
to correctly accuse the culprits who
stole a co-worker's Mochi helping a kid
repair a relationship with a friend
who's moving away slicing up dudes to
protect someone escaping an arranged
marriage and many other bizarre or
amusing divergences this version of
Ryoma Sakamoto gets comically roped into
everybody's business and is just as
naive but good-natured as the Kiryu
we've grown to love there are a ton of
these sub stories as well which can be
overbearing when they automatically
trigger and interrupt the main story's
momentum and while not every one of
these sub stories is worth writing home
about they're always welcome as a reason
to keep playing and experience the
ever-present goofy side of rgg games
like a dragon ishin is a fascinating
part of the rgg studio catalog
creatively blending the characters and
drama we know and love across the Yakuza
law with a period piece set during a
turbulent time in Japanese history by
virtue of its brand of Storytelling
ishin foregoes some of the tropes that
have glorified Samurai but rides that
line ever so closely if the series is
one thing it's consistent because
despite the shift to Edo era Japan
there's an unmistakable familiarity the
days of asking Sega to bring ishin to
the West are thankfully over and
although this revision uses an older
Foundation that shows its age it's nice
to finally have a version of the game
that has been tidied up for modern
platforms like a dragon ishin brings an
All-Star cast back together for a story
that's bigger than any one character and
it makes for a fine addition to the
series deep history
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]